[Music]
rapidly growing consuming adapting they
conquer jeopardizing local economies
threatening human health and devastating
entire ecosystems all rows of cherished
landmarks are condemned brought home to
town dwelling citizens other rigid
precautions being taken by the
department of agriculture to save this
prey from extinction invasive species
are non-native organisms that cause
considerable damage when introduced to a
new area these species compete with
native wildlife for resources and thrive
at the expense of the local ecosystem
the introduction of invasive species is
often associated with human activity
boats that travel between different
bodies of water can carry hitchhikers
such as the zebra mussel one of the most
notorious invasive species in the United
States these rapidly reproducing mussels
clog pipes and overtake beaches in the
Great Lakes some invasive species
however are introduced intentionally in
the early 20th century cane toads were
brought to Australia as a form of pest
control today these poisonous amphibians
number in the millions and have caused a
decline in native predators on the
island
it's not just animals bacteria fungi and
plants can also become invasive brought
to South Africa in the 19th century the
black wattle is an invasive tree often
used for timber and firewood this
beautiful tree and other thirsty
invasives are depleting the country's
already record low water supply because
of their impact on human health
ecosystems and infrastructure invasive
species cost the global economy over a
trillion dollars each year many measures
can be taken to help limit the spread of
invasive species but the most effective
method is prevention but carefully
cleaning boats before transferring
between different bodies of water not
releasing exotic pets into the wild and
planting gardens with native species we
can help prevent the spread of invasive
organisms every living thing has evolved
to play a specialized role within their
ecosystem in the ultimate balancing act
even one invasive species can
drastically tilt the scales if we stay
mindful of our role in the spread of
these organisms we can prevent invasions
before it is too late
[Music]
[Music]